the onslaught began during morning Rush
Hour
at least one missile coming into land in
a busy interception in the heart of the
Ukrainian capital A number of cars
destroyed
another attack in a park a huge crater
right next to a children's playground
but here a narrow Escape both for the
pedestrian bridge
and The Pedestrian on it once again
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
was quick to issue a video message to
Rally his people house
[Music]
[Music]
in Moscow from the Kremlin Vladimir
Putin was explicit this was a warning to
Ukraine he said and the attacks could
well be repeated
a massive missile strike using long
distance air sea and land-based high
Precision weapons was conducted today
targeting energy military command and
communication facilities of Ukraine
should an attempt to conduct terrorist
attacks continue the response from
Russia will be tough and its scale will
correspond to the level of threat
against Russian Federation nobody should
have any doubt about that
foreign
the attacks followed this over the
weekend the key strategic Kirch bridge
between Mainland Russia and Russian
occupied Crimea was left partially
destroyed it was a pet project of
Vladimir Putin's that he personally
opened and a key artery for military
supplies to his forces into Ukraine
ukrainians haven't omitted
responsibility but say it was a valid
military Target
it was illegally built it was built to
connect Russia with illegally occupied
territory of Premier during eight months
it was used for military supplies to
Premiere which was used to supply of
Russian forces in the south of Ukraine
so by definition it was a legitimate
Target
in cave paramedics cover the body of one
of the civilian victims of Russia's
missiles the death toll is climbing
internet Pro dash cam footage captures
the terrifying moment a missile comes
into land in a residential neighborhood
and the secondary explosion that follows
the war in Ukraine has escalated again
and yet again its civilians are paying
the price Dominic wagorn Sky News